another letter schoolchildren make nice
targets and gave himself a name Greek
Morse code astrological signs these guys
use them all I like killing people
because man is the most dangerous animal
of all there's no clock hey it's time
for another episode of 13 o'clock and on
this episode we are finally getting
around to tackling probably the classic
American true crime case of the serial
killer that was never caught
the Zodiac yeah and we've had this like
requested so many times and I'm like
well a lot of people have done shows
about it but we haven't done one and you
know like I said we do true crime and
unsolved mysteries and stuff like that
so you know we had to get around to it
eventually
so we finally did yeah yeah this one
this one we just been pushing back
because really by the numbers this this
ought to be a real common you know I
mean a show on the internet I mean
everybody should know this one but
everybody's requesting it and I guess we
have to do it just to cover the ground
yeah I mean zodiac zodiacs a monumental
case I've read several books about this
case over the years I saw that really
good movie about it yeah a lot of
documentaries about it you know I have
my own opinions about the case
and they they kind of line up with
pretty much it you know everybody else
you know about the case but it was a
good case yeah and honestly the last
couple days I've been reading a lot of
websites zodiac ciphers calm Zodiac
killer comments like reading a lot of
the stuff that's on there and I've
actually kind of changed my mind about a
lot of the prime suspects and stuff like
that now I'm just I'm not entirely sure
if they have any ID
yeah I was in all this is over the years
reading books about it and seeing
programs and just kind of thinking it
over and over again I was never
satisfied that they ever really had the
suspect in their sights I don't think
they I don't even I don't think they
even came close yeah I that they never
even picked this dude up or he was never
even on their radar yeah and I think
what kind of threw him off is that there
was a guy who kind of fit the bill who
seemed to be toying with them that he
was the zodiac yeah well kind of get in
and out yeah yeah red herring yeah yeah
I think it was too and like I said after
after reading a lot of documentation on
this case and you know watching a lot of
different documentaries from different
points of view and kind of focusing on
different people that have written books
about it and whatever yeah I'm kind of
I'm kind of leaning toward yeah but yeah
we'll get into that in a little bit yeah
and actually the news story I have today
is also zodiac related but before we do
that let's do our regular shoutouts now
the faceless villain yeah to the print
version is up there it is for sale yes
it is um we're filming this on Saturday
and it just went up for sale today
now I'm still working on the e-book but
by the time this show goes up on Tuesday
I can't imagine that the e-book wouldn't
be available because it doesn't take
that long I think it only takes 24 hours
and I'm almost done with it and I'm
probably gonna finish up the formatting
tomorrow and get it uploaded tomorrow so
by Tuesday the print book and the e-book
should both be up and then I'm going to
start recording yeah the audio book
early next week now if you are one of
our $20 plus patrons today I just sent
you a free copy like a free digital
proof copy of faceless villain vol 2 so
hopefully you received that you will
also be the first on the list to get a
free audio code when it's route when it
gets released yes so and I also I sent
you guys a message to that it's like on
our December 15th mail out we want to do
t-shirts yes so it
you could like email me back you know
just to the address that I sent the
thing from Google t-shirt yeah email me
back which which t-shirt you want and
what size you want if you want men's
women's whatever we'd like to get all
that information in early yes so we can
find them in the below in terms of the
expenses cuz those suckers are expensive
they like to it is yeah they're kind of
expensive like 20 bucks each so we want
to pay for them over the next code the
next couple we can get everybody's
everybody here and then we can get them
all ripped out like by December 15th
because every three months I usually
send in free stuff oh yeah
whether digital around yeah we got a lot
of designs to choose from we'll help you
pick something out online yes I sent you
link in your email like so just go to
there and pick whichever one you want
tell me what size other stuff so I just
sometime in the next few weeks or month
or whatever so that would be good let's
see our last movie review was the 1978
haunted house movie the evil yeah which
I guess a lot of people hadn't seen we
figured that would probably probably the
case because that's kind of a seat on it
a lot of a lot of people remember - okay
couldn't believe that we knew about it
because yeah well I didn't know you only
remembered it and then we had to like
research and find it one of my jobs yeah
cuz you can remember it was but you
remembered some scenes it was pretty
weird but like I said and I think I
commented this on on the YouTube video
talking to somebody about it and I was
like there's just something about 70s
yeah
horror but like haunted house movies
particularly that I really like it's
like even sucky ones like I get to sit
there and watch him like I watched one
first I watched another one last night
on 42nd Street films channel it was
called the house of the seven corpses
John Carradine in it and John Ireland is
that Kathy Ireland's dad I don't know I
didn't get pulled into it I didn't I
thought its kind of I mean look good but
I was like yeah do you know what
building that was because I was curious
yeah oh that house was gorgeous that was
the Utah governor's mansion haha in Salt
Lake City Mormon palace yeah cuz that
house was like beautiful but yeah it was
it was kind of like it was the same plot
as children shouldn't play with dead
things basically roughly where it's like
it was much actors and they were found
in there and then they accidentally
reanimated the dead oops I remember
watch happens I remember watching those
70s
but movies in the era that they were
made yeah and the reason why they were
scary is because you weren't as a kid or
as a viewer you weren't quite sure what
the state of the art was in terms of
special effects so you weren't quite
sure what they were gonna show you yeah
it was rapid eyes slowly you weren't
sure what was really possible right you
know I mean yeah and as movies got
better and better more and more became
possible and you were just like yeah
floored
damn you know that dude's head flew off
there's something yeah I had a dream
like that the other day a guy blew
himself up and yes I'm weren't really
sure what you were gonna see when I have
dreams like that all the time and really
you know once this one's a special
effects and mature to the level of say
like poltergeist yeah you were like you
were like take it transported to another
world temporarily yes that you could
have never dreamt of that kind of
special effects in the 70s really yeah
yeah I was well honestly a billion is a
thing blew my mind right then because
that's like that was some amazing
[ __ ] special but those are amazing
special effects now yeah but I said well
the thing is it's like any more movies
though they were low-budget so yeah you
weren't gonna see a con now I feel like
you know everything's CGI so it's like
they can show you up anything so it's
just like myth yeah you see it you're
like yeah the big [ __ ] deal yeah well
a big giant robot that's bigger than the
earth right yawn see these good for
backgrounds it's good for background
when you're racing on a track and like
augmentation but it's like I don't like
when they make a whole entire characters
that have CGI yeah because they still
can't get the movement quite right it
doesn't quite look right it doesn't
quite look right it's a little too fluid
and you know it always just takes me
right out of it right I mean you know
I'm not like a Luddite I'm not like one
of those in hate CGI but I think
sometimes you see it it's work you're
like okay yeah it's it's better when
it's you know just very judiciously
applied let's put it that way when you
don't when you're not like creating
whole monsters out of it speaking of
movies we mentioned this last week but
Tom has started his own Facebook group
yeah called Tom's shitty movies [ __ ]
with ds2dio Shi ddy
shitty movies it's on Facebook you can
join the group
we were robbed us
in there already you've got quite a fun
group going there yeah I have certain
standards I do pretty much everybody's
welcome but it yeah I have I have had to
kick a couple of them out if you're too
sensitive don't don't show up to this
group we're in there we're having fun
and you know it's it's kind of a sausage
fest right now we do have some cute
girls in there a little Olivia I've got
Queen Princess she was on one of our up
posters that we did she's in it tear is
there yeah that's it oh they're just you
know so there are girls in there you
know talking but it's mostly guys are
like action films you know and you know
just say no sauce is fast and sometimes
testosterone gets involved and you know
guys I'm just gonna say what they want
to say sometimes and you know there's
certain people from certain cultures
they might get slightly offended and
gotta you know be the bouncer and show
them to the door you know what I mean
well you know it's your I'm not yes my
facebook group I'm not sensitive about
that kind of stuff you know them in just
a sensitive it's just fun if I have a
sense of humor and other people some
people don't have sense of humours you
know a sense of humor I've been talking
to Jay here Jaya from Mexico you know
all day on there sharing videos and
stuff so we do have an international
crowd and he is also encouraged you to
post your own shitty yeah he's
constantly encouraging me that you know
riding with the spirits of kukulcan
through you know through through tequila
I showed him Mex receipt Oh Mexican
Morrissey pants awesome he liked it I
liked that Morrissey was yeah that's
pretty good
there's there's actually a lot of
Mexican Morrison's musasa yeah it's a
whole subculture yeah but I think Metro
C is the best because he's finding it
but yeah I like it they're actually
really good they're very time yeah but
yeah so go if you like action movies and
you like kind of brief sausagefest II
can't see like if you're just listening
to audio podcast you can't see my funny
little hand gesture yeah he's like a
pretty small sausage that's just a
general that's a general okay a bunch of
sausages what am I supposed to do just
put together but so yeah I go check that
out if you like Tom's commentary a lot
of it is you know guys trade information
so you know we're telling each other
about movies and yeah we're just talking
in Klingon and implementation based
relationships you know man we're not
talking about how we feel I know you you
see it happen well yeah but I know you
and I know oh and also I owe them my new
show yeah that's right oh yeah yeah that
came out today remember like a long time
ago any PR called and wanted him to go
to the studio and record an interview
about the mammoth mountain poltergeist
yeah and we had to go back like a whole
bunch of times yeah did that thing
rak'ahs they were like well we didn't
get we wanted to you know have more
information on the other thing so
finally finally yeah a listener just
came and says hey is this buddy you guys
are like yeah and I'm his ready because
miss Lopez didn't tell me that it was
finished yeah although I sent her a
message I approved of it it's yeah it's
short a lot of it is a very abbreviated
right but about Mammoth Mountain but it
was good because I think it was kind of
a quick version of the story and it
didn't have a lot of spoilers about the
book yeah yeah I mean and so if people
are interested in the case then they can
come and get mammoth mountain you know
maybe they're not interested
we didn't waste their time yes it's like
a good teaser video I think it's
probably about maybe 15-20 minutes long
yeah I thought I thought it looked it
was like 20 minutes or talking yeah went
that long or something like that no but
yeah so yeah she she kind of put
together all in this interview that he
did because he is like telling parts a
story they got music and sound effects
in the background you know I mean it's
real it's pretty cool I put I'll put a
link in the yeah it was good it was good
it didn't it didn't it didn't
misrepresent the case that's all I had
told her I said you can do what you want
just don't miss just don't mice
represent what I'm saying and you know
and and and she did that she did a good
job yeah well that's good okay and I
think oh the only other thing that I
wanted to call it and I said this last
week too and we have already got one
submission so the rest of you guys need
to like get in there for our Halloween
show we are going to do reader why do I
keep saying reader I don't know I guess
because I write books yeah but um yeah
we're doing listener submitted they can
be true stories or they can be fictional
as long as they're scary it can be a
true ghost story it can be a true like
just scary [ __ ] that happened to you it
could be a horror story that you wrote
that is fictional
that would be cool too if you would like
us to read it on our extra-special
Halloween extravaganza coming up on I
think the Tuesday is October 30th so
it'll be the day before Halloween
so just submit that to my email account
which is grave cake at gmail.com and I
will put that in the description also so
go ahead and send that like I said we've
already had one really good submission
and I might read some of my fictional
stories too so we'll see how that goes
it'll be a fun show I think we're gonna
do a whole creepy kind of atmosphere
kind of [ __ ] so you know yeah maybe
we'll do like a hint home seance at uh
tight say remember I said I wanted to do
that
to do that we could do like no I don't
have a Ouija board or nothing but we
could like make one maybe you have some
guests over yeah we'll just have a whole
will do communing with yeah maybe we'll
have maybe we'll have Jenny and Dmitry
over yeah Jenna and Dmitry Dmitry that
would be nice actually cuz they've
actually never been on the show
no and I matter of fact they were asking
to come over because he wants me to feed
him butter chicken you don't understand
something people when you have culinary
skills you can't get these people off
you I better check they just want to
come over they want to eat and you know
[ __ ] ruin my diet butter check I do miss
some butter chicken I'm have to make
some butter chickens he makes really
good all food but yeah we'll have it
without rice cuz it gotta make a lower
carb yeah we're trying to do around low
carbs oh not no carb I'm not doing that
[ __ ] cuz like I I still have to have
bread positive right now and then but
we're doing low carb
yeah I've dropped weight and gain muscle
mass but I'm CUBAN yeah and I gotta buy
more weight to them already
I need another or I give it I needed
another 100 pounds at least it's like
girls Cory when they were putting stones
on his chest I'm getting [ __ ] big man
next year me big competition you won't
even be able to fit in the frame I mean
community like your arms be like that
big I'm in competition with Daniel Craig
I'm in competition with crustle I saw
crustle and soldier and I'm like man I
need them shoulders you know yeah I know
and I'm looking at Stallone it dudes
like 72 years old and he's ripped yeah
yeah I mean come on you're you you get
there you're doing good no no no I can
hear much like my office is all the way
across the house from our bedroom yeah
and so like I'm in here working during
the day and I like all I can hear from
the better was like I'm Arnold pressing
like crazy and [ __ ] yeah dumbbells
nothing yeah you're gonna be
you look like Johnny Bravo over the top
yeah all right so that's about all the
shoutouts now let's get to our little
brief news story which I also said was
actually a zodiac related now this news
story I'd look to see if there was an
update on it that was more recent but
there wasn't now the most recent news
stories it was from May 2018 and you
know how we always talk about this new
genealogy website thing where they're
using it to catch all these killers and
stuff like that well they're gonna try
and catch the Zodiac I'd like to see
this using the same method that's down
yes apparently it's more than one stamp
because they were able to get a partial
it wasn't a whole you know Danny a
profile but they did get a partial DNA
profile from either one or more of the
stamps that were on some of the
authenticated zodiac letters from back
in the day and they're going to attempt
to upload this to the GED match
genealogy website and see if there is
some link to some family member that is
perhaps related I'm telling you that was
pre DNA yeah alright so he wouldn't have
been watching for DNA yeah alright if
they got DNA off one of those stamps
that means he licked it yeah he didn't
give it to somebody else it was the
stamp it's the envelope like to close
the envelope - they got some off there
so he wouldn't have bothered to give it
to somebody else to lick or to whatever
that's his DNA yeah because they
wouldn't have been thinking that one it
was like they were they were thinking
about fingerprints and [ __ ] like that
but they don't really think you didn't
find DNA that means he used water but
you know maybe you kind of you know
maybe maybe he just would have done that
just for some kind of weird if there's
DNA on that that's his yeah it wasn't
water because they got a part in a
profile off of it which like I said it
helped them eliminate or possibly
eliminate they might be able to find out
who he is I'm gonna tell you right now
he's what I don't want to spoil it a bit
I I'm pretty sure he's dead
you think he's that I'm pretty sure he's
dead well I don't know we said we said
that about
about that so I'm not gonna I kind of
suspect he might be dead too but I'm not
gonna make any definitive statements in
that line that dude might still be alive
those guys from that generation didn't
live that long right yeah I mean they
had high mortality back then because
their diet and their exercise yeah
chances chances are he's dead yeah you
know yeah if you want to play the odds
he probably ought to his dad's right he
probably is that golden snake killer he
was lucky to have lived for as long as
he did yeah
most guys men generation because their
life expectancy didn't make it to that
yeah especially high risk takers serial
killers gonna be a guy who take risk
well yeah you know one has and has
mental problems too : stay killer I mean
he killed yeah he rapes a lot go gold
and stay killer um
broke the mold he beat the odds yeah he
pretty beat the odds
but [ __ ] caught up with him in the end
not really when I looked at I tell you
he's still kind of one because no matter
what they can only give him a few years
in prison that's true cuz at his age
he's not gonna last long anyway yeah so
I mean I'll never be served well no of
course I mean they should have caught
him back then well but you know what are
you gonna do it's like I'm gonna go to
prison he's gonna go to the prison
infirmary and chill out watch television
until then they're gonna take care of
him yeah until he does he's gonna get
free medical care until he died he won't
be free yeah you know he won't be able
to walk around he won't like that but I
bet you'd going to prison and an ending
it ended up in the infirmary that's what
they're gonna put him at his age yeah
we'll actually extend his life probably
yeah yeah the and the only reason why I
can soap operas and [ __ ] like the only
the only recent news that came out about
him that last time I checked was that
they did decide that they were gonna try
him for all the crimes like in one venue
because before they were arguing as well
should we send him here and there cuz he
killed in so many different counties but
actually they did decide that they were
gonna try them all all for one and let
into one place so that's the last I
heard but yeah so I haven't heard
anything on the zodiac DNA thing since
May I'm I imagine
they have uploaded the partial profile
and are waiting to see if any matches
emerge when that be a [ __ ] wouldn't
that be the [ __ ] if they caught the
[ __ ] zodiac there's a chance cuz he's
kind of like I mean he's just
yeah he's the Holy Grail that's what I
mean it's like there really isn't
another one of that I don't want to say
caliber that magnitude yeah yeah that
magnitude that's a better word caliber
almost makes it sound like pause right
but I don't what does it sound like that
but like um yeah that's not a serious
serial killer fanclub here no we don't
like these [ __ ]
yeah regulate this there's nothing we
don't like these [ __ ] I think there's
gum bags yeah they're bad so you know
what I mean I just marvel that they can
do the [ __ ] that they can do yeah get
away with it and then I would lick
themselves afterwards yeah that's a mix
minute yeah for any new listeners I'm
ex-military guy you know and I've I've
done some [ __ ] I couldn't do it these
dudes dude I couldn't kill a person
that's begging for their lives of
innocent people have done nothing wrong
I can kill a bad person well yeah I
think most people can't you know but if
you're defending yourself you're
defending others you know yeah I can do
that with that but yeah like I'm just an
innocent person yeah this just it's not
armed they're not doing anything to you
actually you know I don't know most
people we're not now sometimes sometimes
a soldier will accidentally his actions
will accidentally result in the deaths
of innocent what we would call an
innocent enemy civilian in other words
innocent a civilian that is on the enemy
side hey you call it collateral damage
um that's really unfortunate but most
guys can even kind of live with that
because you're kind of robotically doing
what you were told and pressing buttons
and rockets and missiles here yeah it's
not like you had to look somebody yeah
and it was not really the intent right
is the the civilians were in the wrong
place at the wrong time and you really
couldn't avoid it really the spot the
responsibility is on an authority above
you yeah so that's how they mitigate
that but what these guys do sit they do
what they do and they love what they do
it's almost like a sexual fetish
involved with murder you know it's
that's the base
basically that's what it is it just
seemed exactly it's murder somehow fused
in with their sex drive yeah well that's
why so many of them are like loners or
you know don't have wives or girlfriend
some of them do but I mean you know most
of the time yeah most of the time I mean
that that whole picture of the serial
killers like this lone creep like living
on the basement and stuff I mean yeah
there's a reason that that's a true if
there if that's who you are I got no
[ __ ] respect for you none I'd have
more respect with for a hitman like the
Iceman you know he was just doing it
least he was doing for a job he was
killing basically guys that were bad
guys other other criminals basically and
he was getting paid yeah and those guys
are all in the meat grinder they're all
in that game that's what they do it's
not good but not good but there's no
innocence involved they're all you
understand similar to soldiers at war
yeah killers are fascinating because if
it's go most people don't understand how
anybody could do that to another person
is on thinking yeah and the same thing
and the same thing when we're talking
about the zodiac so I guess we're going
to take a little short break right now
and when we come back we will get into
the Zodiac case talk about all the
victims I'm gonna talk about some of the
interesting theories that have come out
in the last few years about some various
suspects and you know some of like
weirder theories and [ __ ] like that I
don't want to go too much into that cuz
I don't like oh that conspiracy theory
[ __ ] and most of it's like pretty
stupid but uh yeah so we'll get into it
after the break and we will be back in
just a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay everybody Ginny's got some new
shirts designs up four of them really
good ones to Atlanta Ripper who put
Bella in the which out the HH Holmes
murder castle and of course demon child
cuz man said he could these are updated
designs I think they look really cool
Jenny did a great job
bottom where they found making Jenny
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out right yeah it
really good they're very high quality
shirts Jenny and I we're sure our own
shirts at certain times when we're
trying to put spotlight on ourselves and
you can put a spotlight on yourselves if
you go ahead and pick up on these shirts
today you guys are gonna love them links
in the description
WWL calm at 13 o'clock yes ago check out
our store at wwl calm / 13 o'clock we
got these four cool new t-shirt designs
plus all our old ones if you'd rather
get one at all ones but these ones are
awesome and you should check them out
they're also available in women's cut
they look really cute JD's got some so
thank you go check them out
[Music]
[Music]
that's why is so significant because we
are willing okay we're back in the main
part of the show we're gonna talk about
so the Zodiac killer
but before did we do that I want to
touch back up on the Iceman Kuklinski
earlier on I was thinking about I said
that he only killed gangsters and I was
actually wrong about that oh yeah I was
actually wrong about that he killed
anybody who pissed him off right yeah
somebody cut him off in traffic there
were some kids up in the mountains in a
damn VW Winnebago type the VW bus this
is called a VW bus he got him off he
claims that they tried to drive him off
the road all right and he pulled be God
but he somehow got an advantage over
them and got them to stop the car I
don't remember exactly but he shot at
the driver and then they wrecked that's
what I thought and then he got out of
his car and [ __ ] executed all of them
nothing it was like three or four men
there and he must have told the truth
because that was just part of his
confession yeah you know it's not like
they found those bodies did you do this
no he said no you know I killed some
kids up his mouth and he killed dudes in
bars regularly you know if you yeah if
you were gonna be a tough guy around
kuklinski and talk to yeah he was gonna
follow you out one dude was out there
taking a piss behind the back of the bar
and Kuklinski's slipped up behind him
and put a garrote around his neck and
strangled him to death why was hanging
him over his back said the piss was
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's just I was like that
and he just waited waited and waited and
then once it was about 10-15 minutes
passed he just dropped him and walked
off like nothing happened he's a bad
[ __ ] I tell you what out all
those multiple murderers with guys with
high body counts in a way I kind of
grudgingly respect that dude because he
was a very disciplined hit man very
disciplined I mean other than when he
got pissed you know yeah that doesn't
strike me well you know he was in
thugs yeah yeah now and it's easy for
pissin matches to break out amongst
world you know I'm up the world of thugs
you know I didn't want to step on that
dude's dick if I ever man if I ever got
into a position where they got sent to
jail and they put me in a Cell the
kuklinski I'd become Quincy's best
friend hi how are you doing mr.
kuklinski cuz they're gonna kill you in
a heartbeat
oh yeah yeah I wouldn't to cross that
dude oh yeah you gotta sleep in the same
[ __ ] yeah cross that do that all now I'd
be reading them bedtime stories and [ __ ]
ease up and stuff from the back I'm
reading bedtime stories to them and try
to be as valuable as that [ __ ] could
head dude I'm just going to get on with
the main case right so we're going to
talk about the Zodiac killer now we're
going to go through a little bit of a
timeline it's like most people kind of
know the you know ins and outs of this
case but we'll kind of just go over it
very briefly now there have been many
other cases that are like possible
zodiac cases that occurred before the
first canonical one so we'll get into
those a little bit later but the first
crime that is definitively attributed to
the zodiac occurred on December 20th
1968 and this is known nowadays as the
Lake Herman Road attack year before I
was born
yeah yeah now this was Betty Lou Jensen
and David Faraday they were high school
students David Faraday was 17 Betty Lou
Jensen was 16 this was their first date
actually it was Betty Lou Jensen's first
date with any one man those are kids
yeah
maybe where were high school kids yeah
yeah yeah so this was their first date
um they were actually planning on David
had barred his mother's Rambler and they
were actually going to go to a Christmas
concert at a high school nearby that was
only a few blocks away but then they
decided you know they were gonna do some
other so if they went and visited some
friends they went Nate at a restaurant
and then they decided that they were
going to go up to Lake Herman Rhodes
of out of the way sort of Road you know
what kind of a known Lovers Lane that a
lot of the teenagers and [ __ ] went up
there and I actually watched a
documentary recently where Aphrodite
Jones that yeah I wrote that true crime
writer yeah she went to this place I'm
actually her replacement her yeah yeah
but I don't know when this documentaries
made moved 2007-2008 yeah maybe it was
later but she actually went to the
sample and it pretty much looks the same
there's no it's very dark there's no
streetlights there's nothing really out
there so they go up there and park and
then about you know they hadn't been
there very long I guess they were just
sitting there in the car listening to
the radio and then all of a sudden
someone just walks up and shoots both of
them was a 22 pistol yeah now these two
victims were both killed outright
by the time the cops got there they were
both dead
so they yeah so um actually they found
David Farraday in the car they actually
found Betty Lou Jensen about 28 feet
from the car so she had actually jumped
out of the car and tried to run away and
then the zodiac shot her in the back
five times that's really odd when you
think about it this guy must be really
insecure about himself in terms of
sexuality because I think the average
serial killer or a lot of circles were
tracked her down raped her before you
shot her yeah he wasn't so much into the
raping um he mostly which tells me he
couldn't deliver he was kind of like
when he says you know yeah yeah some
reason he thought the act of raping her
would be would embarrass him it could be
he seems like I said he seemed more like
he didn't really get any it almost
seemed like he liked the the hunt
yeah sort of he made like a lot of
references to the most dangerous game
that's full of [ __ ] he was inadequate
yes so he he just liked going up in July
shooting random people like I said I
think that he thought of himself or he
tried to portray himself as like this
big badass and stuff but really was
kind of cowardly because we was just
walking up to like teenagers and cars
yeah
shooting into the car yeah I mean these
are little kids I mean yeah how much
older do you think he was I bet you he
wasn't that much older really well some
of the descriptions vary I'm the one of
the guys that survived that saw him said
he was in his late 20s he said 26 to 30
okay so he's actually worse than I
thought
yeah because a thirty year old man
against teenagers that's what I mean
that's why I'd always seen yeah yes
low-hanging fruit no how was this
big-game hunting I mean a big if you're
if you're a serial killer that so well
this is all about the hunt of the big
game honey why aren't you tracking down
cops yeah that would be the big game now
their attack a police department yeah
well I mean there was a couple attacks
later on that may have been him it
actually may have been boys really yeah
killing yeah killing a little kids okay
yeah yeah but the first two that were
attributed to him right um were
teenagers 16 year old and 17 year old
those were both killed and that was a
few days before Christmas in 1968 that's
a first date few days before Christmas
yeah terrible I know it's horrible
lowdown and um you know so at this point
now this is in Vallejo California I mean
there was like there was hardly any
crime I mean like I've seen interviews
with like a lot of the investigators and
the cops that worked in the case um
rather see the Golden Age of California
yeah they were like this this just never
happened it's like you know what I mean
so so it was just like a big deal and
obviously at this point nobody knew it
was a serial killer they just thought it
was some weird [ __ ] random ass crime
but even from the beginning they knew
that there was no motive and that's why
they were like freaking out about it
because this is no way it was some
robbery it was a rape it wasn't anything
it's like he just shot them and left
that's it very reminiscent a Son of Sam
at this point yeah
now the loser yeah well like I said
they're losers but yeah so the next one
that is attributed to him happened
actually on the fourth of July 1969
this was Darlene Ferrin and Michael
madjoe same kind of thing they had
driven to a sort of Lovers Lane kind of
spot it was at Blue Rock Springs Park
they were in the parking lot that was
also in Vallejo this was about four
miles away from the site of the first
crime so they were sitting in Darlene
ferrin's car she had driven she was in
the driver's seat and they were sitting
there listening to the radio and
apparently what happened was this guy
drives into the parking lot and pulls up
beside them but then drives away again
then ten minutes later the same car
comes back and pulls him right behind
them so they can't get out then they see
this guy coming out and he comes around
to the passenger side where Michael
madjoe was sitting and he has a
nine-millimeter Luger yeah and he starts
shooting into the car now at this point
some of the bullets the first bullet I
believe went through Michael Meadows
face like it went through his throat
or his jaw and it came out like his
cheek now a lot of the bullets went
through him and into her hmm now he
panicked and like started climbing into
the backseat and then the the killers
kept shooting and shooting and through
the driver side and kept shooting
Darlene now he was also shining a
flashlight in there so they couldn't
really get that good a look at his face
now he's shot a bunch of times and then
he walked away but then evidently he
heard Michael Maggio or Darlene Ferrin
groaning and came back and shot them
both again two times each so there were
no survivors no Michael manager lives
okay actually um and I saw the weapon
yes okay it was a Luger yes it was
nine-millimeter yeah it's weird because
that's kind of a you know that's kind of
a strange pistol he used in 68 yeah
there's a lot of little technical things
I mean the nine-millimeter Luger pistol
didn't shoot normal nine millimetre
parabellum ammunition that you would
find in 68 yeah it shot a special load
called nine-millimeter Luger which is a
lighter bullet and the shorter it was it
was a milder load because not a Luger
and nine-millimeter is a toggle action
firearm
which is a very archaic design there are
a pretty elegant pistol they really are
I'm gonna say he misidentified that
pistol because even in 68 that was kind
of out of date kind of rare collector's
pistol more or something that you would
just keep it home then actually you well
I bet you it was a p38 they did well no
they did find shell casings and also in
one of the zodiacs letters he said that
that was Bissell he had use he did yeah
now not it not weird attack the first
attack was a 22 caliber right the second
one he said was a 9-millimeter and okay
well they all use the same casings it's
just the load that goes inside the KS
but he said it was a night another Luger
that's that's weird I mean there were
more of them back in 68 you know I know
these firearms there more of them
existed back in 68 I guess you could say
in 68 it would have been a little bit
more practical to use it back then than
it would be today but even back in 68
that was kind of an outdated pistol
yeah and Rick and it required you to buy
nine-millimeter Luger which was nine
millimetre parabellum loaded down to a
little bit more mild so that means you'd
had to go to a store and specifically by
nine-millimeter Luger load which was you
could narrow down maybe who the who the
purchaser was back then yeah but you
know maybe that's that's so long ago and
they didn't keep records for ammunition
sales yeah but that would have been that
was just a weird choice which tells me
there's a chance that he didn't buy that
gun that he got that gun from his dad
yeah that's what I'm saying that's ad I
fee I'm feeling that yeah that that was
a weapon that he actually inherited in
some way wasn't something he went out
and bought yeah could've been right so
that might be a clue um okay so about an
less than an hour after the attack a
call comes in to the Vallejo Police
Department and the guy that called says
there's been a murder you know go to
this area and you'll find the two kids
in a
car and he said oh by the way I also
killed those two kids last year now the
woman that took the or the dispatcher
that took the call
she said that he then he had a very
particular way of speaking his voice was
very monotone and she said that at the
end of the call she said he made this
really really creepy like goodbye like
that like he was taunting them type of
thing so um yeah so she heard that so
they go and they find now when they got
there Darlene Ferrin and Michael Maggio
were actually both still alive um
Darlene Ferrin was pronounced dead at
the hospital
like she died on the way to the hospital
Michael Maggio survived amazingly even
though he'd been shot a whole bunch of
times in the face and the neck and stuff
yeah there's a reason but he nine
millimetre parabellum is in Full Metal
Jacket it does not make a very vicious
wound
yeah even 9-millimeter Luger which is a
milder version of it fires Full Metal
Jacket it's a lighter bullet I think was
only 92 grains moving maybe like a
thousand 50 maybe I think was a thousand
50 coming out of a something like a
Luger it that particular load leaves a
wound very similar to an ice pick yeah
you know no man so you shoot somebody up
with it and not cause a lot of traumatic
damage it can't kill you it's just that
it's not very destructive yeah yeah not
good stopping power but at this this
attack evidently the killer was not
wearing a mask or anything like that
room so Michael Mann show did see his
face but only kind of from the side
because of the flashlight because of the
trauma and everything like that so he
couldn't but he did say that the killer
looked about 26 to 30 years old um that
he was heavyset he said not blubbery fat
but like beefy like a like a big beefy
build he said about 195 200 pounds maybe
more he said he was about five foot
eight white male and he said he had
short light brown curly hair huh so
that's how he described him now this was
um the phone call came in on the morning
of July 5th now less than a month later
on August 1st
1969 this is where the whole Zodiac
mythos begins to kind of take hold
because this is when the infamous zodiac
letters begin arriving now the first
ones to arrive it was three letters one
of them came to the offices of the
Vallejo times-herald one came to the San
Francisco Chronicle and one came to the
San Francisco Examiner now each of these
letters had a third of a 408 character
cryptogram now the killer said he you
know he said which crimes he was
responsible for and he said you know he
wanted the cryptogram published on the
front pages of the paper or else he
would kill a bunch more people so some
of the newspapers they weren't really
sure if this was actually from the
killer if it was just a prank you know
how are you supposed to know you don't
know so I think one of the newspapers
actually did publish it on the front
page the other ones didn't I think one
published on page four and then they put
a letter next to it that said you know
if this is really the killer send us
more [ __ ] you know so we know it's
really you and stuff like that but yeah
so they say they print this cryptogram
now he said that if you could solve the
cryptogram then it would say who he was
right well only a day or two after the
cryptogram was published a teacher
actually solved it
other than like the last 18 letters
which have never been figured out
they're just too gibberish but the rest
of the message you know it said stuff
like I like killing people it's so much
more fun than killing wild game man is
the most dangerous animal of all you
know and then he's saying he's
collecting slaves for his afterlife
that's why he's killing these people and
then it says at the end of the
cryptogram it says I'm not really gonna
give you my name because then you'll
slow down my slave collection he's
tripping and [ __ ] yeah crazy [ __ ] yeah
so yeah even he didn't believe that no
I'm probably not
so then about a week later the San
Francisco Examiner gets another letter
and this is the one the first one where
the killer identifies himself as the
Zodiac because it started out dear
editor this is the zodiac speaking
and he actually in this one he was
actually responding to the examiner
printing the cryptogram and saying we
want more proof that this is you and he
gave a whole bunch of clues in the
letter that you know facts about the
crimes that were not public knowledge
that probably that only the killer would
have known so then at that point they
knew that it was actually him so then
the next attack that took place this is
the one that always scared me because I
saw a movie not like the the David
Fincher one that came out in 2007 which
was based on Robert gray-smith spoke
which is actually really really good but
there was another one and I can't
remember what year it came out it must
have been like late seventies early
eighties something like that and this
was the part that scared me the most
that like freaked me out so much this is
the Lake Berryessa attack this happened
on September 27th 1969 this was Bryan
Hartnell and Cecelia Shepard they were
college students and they were having a
picnic out on Lake Berryessa and Cecelia
actually saw she said to Bryan she's
like there's a man over there behind
that tree and she started getting like
nervous about it now what I didn't know
until I watched a whole bunch of
documentaries about it say was she saw
his face she saw him before he put the
mask on hmm because she I guess he was
peeking out from behind the tree like
looking and she was getting really
nervous and Bryan was just like whatever
he's just probably taking a leak or
something you know what I mean so he was
like kind of blowing it off but then he
comes out from behind the tree and he's
got on the whole getup which is very
famous now
like the executioner's hood he has like
this clip-on sunglasses over the
eyeholes he has that kind of big thing
that has the zodiac symbol on it yeah
you know the little crosshair type the
famous zodiac outfit yeah like an
execute
hood yeah and he's holding a gun and
he's got a big night like a bayonet
style quite imagination that man he does
it so we're for the dramatics yeah now
this man was awesome was also later
described he's as a white male he was
described as about 511 the other guys
said 5/8 but you know why was clothes
off um said he was hefty like beefy kind
of guy not fat but you know just like
kind of a big beefy dude um he said that
he had kind of greasy brown hair now he
came up to them
Brian Hartnell said he thought the gun
was a 45 but he wasn't real sure so the
guy says to them that he's like I just
want your money and your car I escaped
from prison and I killed a guard I think
he said he escaped from prison in
Montana and he's like in the car I have
now is you know it's stolen it's hot so
I need your car so you know they were
cooperating they were like okay just
take whatever you want now he made
cecelia tie up Brian and then he tied
her up but see Cecelia tried to tie up
Brian like loosely but zodiac checked
and he like tightened it all up so they
were like hogtied on this blanket like
facedown and evidently Brian heart now
Liz was like trying to talk with the guy
and was trying to kind of reason with
him yeah just take what you want you
know I don't have much money but you can
have it you can have my car's up there
on the road or whatever and all this
other kind of stuff and then at that
point the zodiac is like well I'm just
gonna have to kill you and then he just
starts stabbing like he didn't shoot
them he's just stabbed them he just
stabbed him in stabbed and stabbed and
stabbed over and over and over again
yeah now what I didn't realize again
until I watched a thing and I actually
saw an interview with Brian Hartnell who
actually survived the attack Cecelia
Shepard did not it's amazing that he
survived that it is yeah he was stabbed
a whole bunch of times and um the the
scary thing was I didn't realize but
they they both got stabbed and they were
both tied up and then the guy took off
and they were laying there for a really
long
before anybody helped them they were
like yelling they said boats were going
by but like either people didn't hear
them or thought they were just [ __ ]
around or whatever and then finally they
said this boat came by with a guy and
what she liked to for a while yeah they
were both alive for a while and actually
he managed well she managed to get um
loosened up kind of they were trying to
untie each other's hands yeah like they
were trying to like roll over and so he
actually kind of got loose and he was
able to get loose and he was gonna try
and go get help but then when he stood
up he kept passing out because he has a
blood loss yes
so they actually you know did try to get
away but then finally this boat comes by
with a guy and his son in it and they
went to a park ranger and reported but
safe so they laid there for a long time
like losing blood yeah um you know again
so so Brian Hartnell survived Cecilia
did not now up on Brian Hartnell's car
which was parked up on the road they
found that the zodiac had written with a
kind of a felt-tip pen or a marker on
the side of the door on the side of the
car door and he had made his little
zodiac symbol and then he wrote Vallejo
12 2016 8 which was the Lake Herman
heart attack 12 or 7 for 69 which was
the Blue Rock Springs attack September
27 69 which was the one he just did then
he put six thirty
and then underneath he put by knife yeah
so I remember seeing photos yeah so yeah
there's there's photos of it you know
get terrible handwriting - it was very
terrible and his spelling was also a
little kid yeah so just like in the
previous attack about an hour after this
particular attack the Napa County
Sheriff's Office gets a phone call and
the person on the other end the line
says I want to report a murder
no a double murder and he's like oh and
by the way I did it now they were able
to trace the call to a payphone by the
Napa carwash and they they found the
phone when they found the phone that the
receiver was still hanging off the hook
and they were actually able to lift a
partial palm print because it was still
like a damp palm print
like on the receiver of the phone from
the killer now what the zodiac would do
is that I mean the the payphone it was
like 30 it was like 27 30 miles from the
crime scene but it was really close to a
police station so he almost really likes
he would like kill people then he'd
drive a long way like to really close to
a police station then call from right
there because it's almost like a bigger
challenge I guess cuz he was like hey
I'm right here and you can't catch me or
something like my good but yeah that
happened a couple of times so as I said
you know Cecelia Shepard was actually
conscious for a little while
and did give a description of the killer
to police because as I said she had
actually seen him peeking out from on
that tree before he put his mask on so
they were able to get a statement from
her unfortunately she passed away she
went into a coma in the ambulance and
then died later on without ever without
ever regaining consciousness
um and then yes she died two days later
but Bryan Hartnell did actually survive
now the last attack that is definitively
attributed to the zodiac was a little
bit of a you know kind of a deviation
from his regular pattern and it happened
two weeks later this happened on October
11th 1969 and a guy gets into a cab
driven by 29 year old Paul Stine and he
asks to go to Washington and maple
streets in Presidio Heights neighborhood
just kind of an upper-class area of San
Francisco so evidently Stein drives to
Maple but he goes one block past then he
pulls over the side of the road and then
someone shoots him in the back of the
head now interestingly there were three
teenagers who were at a house like
across the street like on the second or
third floor and they were out in a
balcony or having to be looking out a
window and they saw the crime occurring
they
the guy get out of the cab and start
wiping down the cab so they called the
cops as you would was he wearing a mask
no okay
so actually the the very famous sketch
of the Zodiac killer she with a guy with
the glasses and stuff like that
that is where this comes from this comes
from their description of the guy that
they saw getting out of the cab after
Paul Stein got shot hmm so Paul Stein
was also shot with a 9-millimeter now
the killer took his wallet and took his
car keys and also tore off a bit of his
shirttail which had blood on it but yeah
so Paul Stein was dead at the scene like
I said this was kind of unusual because
usually he targeted people you know
couples and cars they don't know exactly
why he specifically just shot this cab
driver for whatever reason now the
interesting thing about this is this is
kind of um you know some people say this
is like oh well they could have caught
the Zodiac at this point because
evidently the the cops get there not too
long after cuz like I said the teenagers
called it in like wallet was still going
on like all the guy was still there so
the cops were kind of around and they
got there and they see like this one
officer Don Fouke he's only two blocks
away from the crime scene and he sees a
guy walking along the sidewalk and kind
of stepping up into a house but he said
that this guy now see at this point I
don't know if the teenagers reported it
wrong or if the dispatcher took it down
wrong but the first report that went
onto the radio for the suspect was this
is a black man even though it wasn't it
was a white man but they don't they're
not really show me what wires got
crossed somewhere and it was like a
mistake it was a mistake so some people
have said well the guy that foul walking
down the street because he said oh well
I saw somebody and said hey did you see
somebody walking along here and he said
yeah I saw a guy running up toward the
Presidio like the park probably what it
was they saw a guy wearing
black because the zodiac war yeah it
might black would say probably just saw
something wearing a black got mixed
around but it was a black man yeah they
might have been yeah but the thing is
that the guy that foul saw he said that
it looked like an older guy like a like
a guy in his 40s and that the guy that
the teenagers said that they saw getting
out of the cab was younger like some of
the other people that said the zodiac
was like a mid to late 20 minutes so a
few days after Paul Stine gets shot The
Chronicle gets another letter from the
zodiac and they know it's from him
because in the letter is the piece of
Paul Stine's bloody shirt that the
killer tore off the guy before he got
out of the cab and the letter said that
he was going to target a school bus that
he was going to shoot out the tires and
then he was going to shoot all the kids
like pick them off as they came out of
the school bus yeah I remember I already
read that letter there was more to it
than that too well mostly yeah it had
some like photo sensors with [ __ ]
drawings of photo sensors with like I
guess you could say certain types of
explosives that was yeah yeah
they were kind of worried about that one
of the books that I read they don't
worry yeah they thought the guy might
have had some explosives knowledge well
the thing about yeah because a lot of
the diagrams that he sent um looked like
they would actually work yeah and he was
going around shooting random people so
you can't I mean any threat he makes you
have to take it seriously because what
if he really does that [ __ ] this time
what was he shot with that was also a
9-millimeter okay so it must have been
that Luger yeah they think yeah okay
yeah all right so he's using the same
gun yeah
and this is about how long later it's in
the same year right yeah this was um
well he got shot on October 11th 1969
and then the letter talking about it
came three days later no I'm talking
about the first time you used the
nine-millimeter that was about what a
year before yeah okay although like I
said the first crime it was a 22 yeah
the 20 mm item elevator
and about a year or so later he still
used the nine-millimeter yeah yeah
because if I remember correctly he he
stops using that 9-millimeter and
switches to a 45 no because this was
this last one it was yeah cuz I remember
there was a drawing of him with the air
you sure stood on them like well that
was the Lake Berryessa attack and Brian
Hartnell said he thought it was a 45 but
those victims weren't shot they were
stabbed okay he had it in his hand but
use it because I can react and really
remember the picture of him with the in
his hand he's carrying a knight in 1911
but no one was fought and no one was
fired he may have misidentified that
9-millimeter as a 45 so the artist just
wrote drew drew a 1911 45 yeah oh yeah
so yeah so that was that was another
letter now a few days after that a phone
call comes in to the Oakland Police
Department and this is somebody claiming
to be the Zodiac and they said this
person said I want either Deathly Bailey
or Melvin belli who were very famous
attorneys in the area I want them to be
on the radio show em San Francisco and
I'm gonna call in and talk to them hmm
so f lee Bailey was not available so
Melvin Bell I said he would do it now
this guy called in and claimed he was
the zodiac he said you could call him
Sam and you can actually hear the audio
of it you know online it's everywhere if
you just do the search for it now the
interesting thing about this though is
that the dispatcher the woman at the
Vallejo Police Department who had taken
the first phone call up from the zodiac
that was claiming responsibility for the
murders said that doesn't sound like his
voice and also the survivor said it
didn't sound like his voice either now
evidently according to zodiac ciphers
calm and Zodiac killer calm which are
kind of like these huge databases of
information about these sites it's like
thousands and thousands of pages
apparently this call was traced and it
was a prank it was from a guy named Eric
while and he was calling from it from a
mental hospital
absolutely okay um and there was some
other [ __ ] about him too like he did all
kind of weird [ __ ] which is Bob Dylan
and stuff but you know yeah he was just
like a brand-new better man and weirdest
so
so that they're pretty sure that wasn't
him but like I said people that had
heard the actual zodiacs voice they knew
that wasn't him they said that doesn't
sound like his voice because they said
the zodiac had a very distinctive voice
like you would know it if you heard it
cm described it throws a deep voice well
they said it was kind of a deep voice
very monotone okay that was one thing
that a bunch of them said but they said
it was very deep whereas the the guy
that called in his Sam had a slightly
higher pitched more tenor kind of voice
so yeah it did it didn't really sound
the same so then so the Zodiac keeps
sending more cards there's one on
November 8th that had another cryptogram
this one has actually never been solved
I don't know if it actually means
anything or if it's just gibberish that
he was just doing it's a toy with the
authorities which he seemed to like to
do so maybe it doesn't mean anything but
it still hasn't been solved and then
November 9th of 1969 the zodiac sent a
really long letter was like 7 pages and
in Venice he actually claimed and this
might go back to what officer Phalke was
saying about seeing this guy after Paul
Stine got shot the zodiac claimed he's
like two cops stopped me and talked to
me three minutes after I shot Paul Stine
and they didn't know it was me and they
let me go so that might have I don't
know if he was making that up made that
up but but I don't think there were two
cops I think was just one cop and he saw
a guy and the guy he saw like I said
didn't say he was like a slender guy
that was older I don't buy that yeah see
I'm bragging yes I don't know if that's
because I think I was just trying to
make them look like Johnny Massey
yeah he's turning merely humiliate the
police yeah that didn't happen because
he did say stuff to them like you know
get off your fat asses the more you
fiddle and further problems would have
remembered that that they talked to a
guy within around that same time that
that homicide went down they would have
remembered that right now kind of the
next major thing that happened and
they're pretty sure that this was
actually a Zodiac attack is actually
kind of a close call um this happened in
Modesto on March 22nd 1970 and this was
a woman named Kathleen John's she was
seven months pregnant and she was
traveling with her ten month old
daughter in the front seat
Carr she was actually driving from San
Bernardino to Petaluma she was going to
visit her mother she's on the highway
highway 132 and the car behind her
starts honking his horn and flashing its
headlights and all the soda and you know
and she's like what the hell's maybe
something's wrong with my car so she
pulled over and this guy pulls in behind
her he comes up to her and he says I
noticed that what your rear driver's
side wheel was like was wobbling the lug
nuts are probably loose I'll fix it for
you so she's like okay thanks so he goes
back there and [ __ ] around he's like
okay fine now and then he drives away
now she goes to pull back on the highway
and the wheel falls off how he loosened
him yeah yeah so then I bet she didn't
figure that out though it's like so the
guy comes back and he's like oh man look
at that he's like well I'll Drive you
and the baby to a garage right so they
get in his car now he drives them around
for like an hour and a half like they
she's driving around and she's like hey
we're passing all these gas stations
with the [ __ ] and then he kept like
deflecting her questions
now finally reports differ some said
that she grabbed the baby and jumped out
of the car while was moving some said
she jumped out of the car while he was
stopped at a stop sign or a stop light
or whatever but at any rate her and the
baby jumped to the [ __ ] out of the car
and ran and likely done hid in a field
sources also differ about whether the
guy then got out of the car with a
flashlight to look for her or whether he
just took off but at any rate you know
she hid long enough and he eventually
left when other cars started coming by
she got a lift to the nearest police
station with a woman that was passing
and she goes to the police station to
make a report and she looks up on the
wall and she sees the police sketch of
the man that killed Paul Stine who is
the zodiac she says that's him that's
the guy that just picked me up hmm so
they so yeah so then later they go out
and they find her car and it's been all
burned out somebody set it on fire huh
he went back there yes so he went back
and set her car on fire evidently so
weather no one is absolutely positive
that this was the zodiac but
and and I don't know because in one
report she said that he said that he was
gonna kill her and the baby you know in
another Porsche city didn't say that but
so you know what I mean it's like
there's always kind of he said she said
only different sources and [ __ ] where'd
this happen again this was in it was on
Highway 132 in Modesto Modesto yeah okay
so I was wondering maybe if that was
might have just been some random crime
because it's impossible yeah cuz if
there was an abandoned car that we have
gone to quit somebody just drawn but
driven by and gonna burn a car but
Modesto I from I would think in 68 would
have been kind of rural yeah or suburban
yeah but if this is generally because
this is under this isn't under confirmed
zodiac attacks with this under like
suspected zodiac attacks it sound like
zodiac doesn't kill a person to Susie
sees him yeah there they are and then
shoots him under stabs him and leaves
yeah and I mean she saw his face
she was driving around put them in the
car and you would think that half you
would think that zodiac would have been
kind of skeptical about going back to
where he left that car and putting
himself in danger and setting that thing
on fire yeah that's another thing that'd
be kind of risky although shooting a
cabdriver in the middle of a residential
street is also pretty risky and they're
pretty sure he did that yeah so maybe it
was it was a kind of thing where it was
just like ramping up you know did he
confess to that he did yet well they
knew he did it because the letter you
sent right right that's right that's
right so at this point there are then
that he starts just like sending the
blanket he evidently did not kill any
more people that they know of but we
can't what here's a question though so
he's got a pregnant woman in his car
yeah with a little bit with a kid yeah
which is a nine years old ten months ago
a baby baby yeah why did he kill
immediately if you just if he would just
kill if he would kill a taxicab driver
in the middle of a residential area
why'd he just gunned them down this to
me what I'm thinking is this particular
report sounds like an attempted rape to
me
yeah that's just what it sounds like I'm
gonna kind of lean towards that and
probably that may have never been as Oh
it might not there's no way and actually
no and like I said the fact that she
came into the police station said hey
that was the guy yeah but yeah I don't
know it's like that guy looks like a lot
of guys so I don't you know I don't just
sounds like the city I would just keep
Zodiac is you just killed people just to
meet pretty much immediately yeah like
an ambush attack it does seem like yeah
he would I just would have been more
likely to hear to walked up to why she
was in the car and just shot her and the
kid and then walked off that all this
stuff about ruses to get her into his
car that just didn't sound like
something he could do yeah because that
sounds like you usually abduct someone
so you can rape them yeah and as far as
we know confirm zodiac killings didn't
really involve any abduction no he
usually just killed him on the spot yeah
he didn't like dump him anywhere there's
a good chance that that is not a Zodiac
attack zodiac attack [ __ ] out to make a
song for that there's probably already
yeah yeah I would
I kind of feeling that isn't a zodiac it
may not be like I said but it's
suspected it's suspected just because
she identified um and they know that the
Zodiac killer Paul Stine's so and the
fact that she identified the same perp
um you know so it's kind of so as
possible kind of a common description
now kind of a meeting so then there were
some more letters a couple more ciphers
that have not been decrypted as of this
stage um he actually he would he would
take credit for more crimes he because
sometimes at the bottom of the letters
he would have like a little like body
count so he would have like his little
symbol I remember and then he'd be like
like one of the ones that he sent in
February 1970 hit his little symbol and
then he said equals 10 and then San
Francisco Police Department zero like
I've killed 10 people and you haven't
caught me for any of them so and at this
point they only knew about him attacking
seven people and killing five people
because two of them survived now he
actually did say that there had been an
attack in February 18th it was
was a bombing that killed a cop sergeant
Brian McDonald and he actually said that
that wasn't him
even though he said that it was much
better hunting cops because they can
shoot back yeah like better than
civilians then yes guy had the balls
then he started like think he was sound
like greeting cards you know threatening
to bomb places he sent maps with like
these kind of Radian type things I know
there's a bomb here that's gonna go off
in a few months and they never found
anything and he wanted people to wear
buttons with his symbol on it or I'm
gonna blow [ __ ] up if you don't wear
those even though I don't think anybody
ever did but yeah because he cuz he kept
writing and saying he was upset that
nobody it was wearing them and all this
other stuff now one letter that he wrote
and I thought this was actually kind of
interesting he wrote a letter it was
postmarked June 26 1970 and he wrote in
it I shot a man sitting in a parked car
with a 38 now this might have referred
cuz a lot of times he would say I did
this and that and they couldn't really
find a crime that corresponding to it
but this one there was one um and this
was actually a cop his name was Sergeant
Richard I don't know how to pronounce
his last name Rattata CH I guess is how
you pronounce it Richard Rattata CH and
this had been a week earlier on June
19th he was writing a parking ticket he
was at a sitting at his squad car
writing a parking ticket and somebody
just came up and shot him in the head
with a 38 so they don't know the San
Francisco Police Department said no this
wasn't the zodiac with the zodiac dudes
he did say that he shot a man with a 38
and they may have read a newspaper good
Matthew because it had been it had
happened a week earlier and like I said
they that's the thing they don't know
cuz like sometimes he would say yeah I
killed this many people and he would
take credit for things because he did
later take credit in a letter for the
Kathleen John's saying he didn't name
her yeah but he said he referred to a
woman and her baby that I gave an
interesting ride to write like one night
and stuff but like you said that could
have been he could have just read in the
paper and be like oh I'm taking credit
for that [ __ ] right so maybe he did it
maybe he's in I don't know I was under
the impression
rushon that he got to a point where he
realized he didn't actually have to
commit the crimes he can just take
credit is what he started to say was I'm
gonna break my pattern and not leave my
sign there and you'll never know it was
me
yeah so you won't know if it was if I
did it or if somebody else did it that
was in a way kind of copping out of the
whole serial killer got lazy with a thin
a whole serial killer a thing with
leaving your damn sign behind and
everything you know yeah there's a way
of kind of like getting out of it and
taking credit for other people's
homicides yeah
and I really kind of think you only
killed what three five they've confirmed
that yeah one woman okay and then the
two Lovers Lane once and who were the
other two no there were three well there
were two Lovers Lane there was one that
was on the beach like the picnicking and
then there was the cabdriver okay yeah
it was seven people yeah but two
survived so it was five deaths no saying
five okay yeah I [ __ ] it was all I got
I think it was it well that's all that's
confirmed right like I said now there
are some other similar crimes that would
happen before then it happened after
that that may have been him um but
they're not real sure so I think he got
lazy and got scared yeah I think he
thought he was gonna get caught so he
started to give him ways a ways out of
actually having to commit the murders
and giving himself way to take credit
for other people's murders yeah now that
was that was even the theory that some
of the investigators had back in those
days cuz I read the books that they
wrote yeah that he was putting out
actually he was trying to just take
credit for other people's murders he
didn't want to murder people anymore
yeah I don't I think he I think he
figured he's gonna get God but so here's
the interesting thing too is that as the
years went on some crimes that had
happened prior to the Lake Herman Road
attack in 1968 was the first one were
later is like suspected and the first of
these probably the most famous of these
was the murder of Cheri Jo Bates now
this came to the attention of Paul Avery
who works for the San Francisco
Chronicle and he had actually been
writing
articles about the zodiac and so the
zodiac could actually sent him a lot of
letters and cards like in particular and
but at this point like Paul Avery got an
anonymous letter that said look into the
murder of Cheri Jo Bates from 1966 in
Riverside and that might be a connection
with the zodiac it happened on October
30th 1966 and 18 year-old sherry sherry
Jo Bates she had actually gone to she
was a student at Riverside Community
College she had gone to the library
there to do some studying for a term
paper that she had coming up she was
there for about three hours she left
when it closed at about nine o'clock she
had a Volkswagen Beetle that was parked
about a hundred yards from the building
evidently she went to start it and it
wouldn't start they found out why later
on they found her the next morning kind
of between these two abandoned houses
she had been beaten and stabbed to death
they found out that all the wires from
the Volkswagens distributor cap had been
pulled out so they assumed that the
killer had while she was inside had
[ __ ] up her car and then when she came
out and it wouldn't start he came over
and said hey let me help you and then he
[ __ ] killed her so this this
particular crime for whatever reason
later on the zodiac said something to
the effect in one of his communications
that oh I see you've discovered my
Riverside activity but you guys are just
finding the easy ones so they're
speculating that this might have been
him as well but you know there were some
other suspects for that but this is
actually Cheri Jo Bates is actually in
my book and I kind of talked about some
of the other suspects in there so the
weird thing though is that later on
after Cheri Jo Bates was killed and this
is going back to 1966 in late November
there were all these letters that were
sent to one was sent to the Riverside
police one was sent to the Riverside
press-enterprise and I think one was set
to Cheri Jo Bates his dad and it was
called the confession and in it the
person wrote that they are the one that
had killed and was like she won't be the
first
she wasn't the first and she won't be
the last and then a month later they
found like a poem that was in the
library that she had been in and
somebody had written something like sick
of living unwilling to die with like
with all this foam and the handwriting
looked very much like the handwriting in
the zodiac letters and like I said this
is going this was two years before the
Lake Herman Road attack the first
canonical this was 1966 that they found
this stuff so they just didn't associate
it because the zodiac hadn't done
anything yet they didn't even know who
the zodiac was but this so there was
some kind of reason for thinking that
maybe yeah because you know he had set
similarly worded confessions to
newspapers in the Riverside area after
she was killed
so that was one now another one that's
suspected is happened in March of 1971
or it actually happened in September of
1970 but they didn't find out that it
might have been related to the zodiac
until March of 1971 because the zodiac
sent a postcard to Paul Avery and it had
like these weird it had like a like a
picture from from an advertisement it
had like all these weird phrases like
cut out and pasted it on there that said
stuff like sought victim 12 past Lake
Tahoe areas around in the snow it said
stuff like that and they thought that
maybe it was referring to the
disappearance and probable murder of
Donna lass who disappeared in September
of 1970 she was actually a nurse and she
had just come off her shift and then she
disappeared whatever her body has never
been found but the weird thing was that
after the like the night she disappeared
the next day her landlord and her
employer got phone calls from a random
dude saying oh she had she had a family
emergency and she had to leave town
which was not true
so there was that whole thing to like I
said this is another suspected Zodiac
crime he seemed to take credit for it
and in that sort of oblique way
but she has never been found she is just
missing purpose - it's just - mm-hmm I
mean he could have read about these
cases and well yeah that's what I mean
and that's why they're not sure that's
why they don't want to say it's not a
confirmed so di killed because they're
not sure he might just be claiming yeah
that he did it he strikes me as a guy
that takes credit for everybody he
killed and then tries to take credit for
people he didn't kill yeah same time
he's trying to trying to magnify himself
yeah and these guys lie yeah yeah I kind
of think it's the five the five court
killings because I mean his last letter
that they because a bunch of letters
came that they determined were probably
not him that Ramona pranks you know just
people [ __ ] around um the last one
that they are pretty sure as him is
generally referred to as the Exorcist
letter because he praises the movie The
Exorcist as being the best satirical
comedy I've ever seen and he also put
some like lyrics from The Mikado the
Gilbert and Sullivan musical in there
and he had this in this letter he claims
that he's killed 37 people yeah he's a
liar yes so like I said they don't know
but like I said there have been some
other kind of similar murders that
people have sort of laid at the feet and
if you go to zodiac ciphers or Zodiac
killer com
there's a whole [ __ ] ton of them in
there they're like kind of similar that
you know you can read about that happen
in the same area at around the same time
but some of the ones that most people
talk about when they talk about possible
zodiac crimes probably the most infamous
one other than Cheri Jo Bates is Robert
Dominguez and Linda Edwards
who were actually shot on Gaviota Beach
they were actually out there there was
senior ditch day they were it was there
they were graduating high school and
they went out to this remote beach to
like you know kind of have a good time
and everything and evidently they were I
there was like a they found their bodies
in this like weird Shack like a hobo
shack and he had been they had both been
shot a whole bunch of times in the back
it looked like the killer had like tried
to shoot them or like they were trying
to run away and then he just gunned him
down and
for some reason he dragged them back and
put them in this Shack and he put the
guy Robert Domingo so he put him face
down on the floor and then he put Linda
on her back on top of him and then cut
the top of her bathing suit off so that
her boobs were sticking out even when
she wasn't raped or anything like that
now some of the some of the crime scene
that said it looked like somebody had
tried to burn down the shack but they're
not actually sure if that happened
because of the bodies or if that had
happened at some prior time the main
suspect in this was actually a guy named
George Edward Gill who was kind of a
drifter type of dude but actually they
determined that he was I believe they
determined that he was out of town when
that shooting happened although he was
the guy that had actually built that
little little shack there they identify
the caliber that was also a 22 I think I
just didn't sound like just doesn't say
didn't sound like a zodiac killing to be
yeah he didn't move by that yet a lot of
people have said that that is not
something that he would do and then why
would he burn it down he could he'd like
to present his bodies he wanted that's
another point that's been that that
wasn't like is it but you know like I
said the the Dominguez Edwards murders
you know that kind of happened you know
a little bit earlier so I don't know who
knows there were actually a couple of
people got shot were there yes there
were a couple other ones
Beverly Allen and Larry Payton they were
actually that that was actually kind of
similar they were both the two people he
was talked about though I'm that was an
attempted rape he was talking he was
trying to rape that girl he killed the
dude it didn't went wrong kill them both
that's that's what happened yeah he
tried to hide it tried to cover it up
that's that's not that's not zodiac yeah
but like I said it's one that comes up a
lot comes up but I'm telling you that
that's a different mo yeah but like I
said it's it was a different time so you
know a lot of his other crimes had
different MO and stuff too
there was another crime this is actually
going back to 19
64 this was Johnny and Joyce swindle
they were actually in San Diego they
were on their honeymoon they were very I
think only 19 or 20 years old they were
walking along the beach like near their
hotel and somebody just shot them from a
sniper's point like on a retaining wall
not that far away and then after they
fell to the ground came closer and shot
them at close range and then took off so
that's another one that sounds more like
a zoo yeah that actually does kind of
sound like yeah sound like a Zodiac kind
of crime so yeah that was 1964 so that's
a possible early one too I always say I
had this feeling in my heart though
which is that's hard to [ __ ] explain
that when zodiac actually did kill
someone he left something at the scene
to let people know that it was him to
take credit all this stuff that he was
writing to the cops well I'm gonna stop
leaving my mark [ __ ] [ __ ] I
don't believe that he did I think he was
just trying to put fear in the police to
make him think that he was killing more
people than he really was well I liked I
saw one documentary about it and I liked
that the woman on there just called him
a straight-up terrorist that's exactly
what he was it's like even if he didn't
do and he's like yeah he did kill people
but even at that point he didn't have to
kill any but all you gonna do is
threaten to do it cuz you've done it a
couple of times and everyone was just
gonna like hop too and like freaked out
about it if you're an active serial
killer what you're gonna do is you're
gonna do both things at once you're
gonna tell them I'm gonna hide some of
my crimes and then some of other crimes
I'll let you know it's me what you do is
is you mark every crime that you commit
and then infer that you did all the ones
you didn't commit yeah you know I mean
to make it look bigger there's no reason
to kill someone and not leave your mark
yeah no matter what if you're gonna
leave your mark then leave your you know
if you're gonna kill someone leave the
mark get the credit yeah and then to try
to steal the credit for the ones that
you didn't do that'll make your
footprint look bigger that's what I'm
that's that that's why I'm saying that
the ones that didn't that heat the ones
that didn't have his mark on them I
don't think he did those yeah that you
just talked about sniping somebody crew
you know sniper him and they killed and
then disappearing that's actually kind
of like his MO
you bushwhack someone and run and like I
said that was four years before the
first canonical zodiac yeah yeah maybe
he hadn't thought of leaving a mark at
that time there was actually another one
that I do notice one thing though before
you go to the next case is that when he
stabbed that girl whenever he stabbed
that girl to death she died later he
stabbed the girl more times than he
killed the guy they are tells me that
that dude couldn't get it up yeah
they're assuming that he was a
woman-hater sighs yeah person yeah yeah
he couldn't get it up so he couldn't
rape these people yeah so there was no
reason to abduct someone for rape he
couldn't do it outside yeah now there
was an even earlier one this happened in
1960 and I think I just mentioned it
briefly before Beverly Allen and Larry
Payton
they were both 19 and they were both
also shot in the Lovers Lane now one
thing that was kind of different to the
regular zodiac crime was that now they
found Larry's body still in the car he
had evidently tried to shoot back
because he had a gun in his in a glove
compartment because it was a shoot shot
through the windshield that they
presumed came from his gun so he had
actually tried to fight back now they
didn't find Beverly Allen for a few
months as his pistol was still there
yeah so so zodiac didn't take it no
weird okay but um but yeah he was all
bloody they know that made sense though
if you take some from the scene then
you're linked to it see yeah yeah I mean
they knew Beverly Allen had to be dead
because I mean they found him he was all
they found Larry Payton he was all
[ __ ] up and shot up they found her
jacket it was all covered with blood
they found a piece of her bloody blouse
like under his body yet they found her
busted up glasses but they found her
later on now that's a little bit unlike
zodiac like I said it's not like him to
like transport a victim to someone else
but like I said this was eight years
prior to the the first canonical zodiac
attack so now there were two guys
convicted there were two guys convicted
for this crime Edward Jorgensen and
Robert Brom now they both got life
sentences but then the weird thing was
they got paroled like really really
quick almost like somebody didn't think
that she did it maybe the evidence was
bad yeah so
it's kind of what made people think
maybe it wasn't although I think one of
the early suspects in this and I want to
talk about him a little bit is it was
Edward Wayne Edwards who was an actual
Siri okay yeah and actually I think he
probably killed more people than he is
given credit for and some people have
suspected that he might have been the
Zodiac as well because he was into
killing couples at lovers lanes and he
was at he he was actually convicted for
two of those type of crimes and he was
suspected and many other similar type of
crimes just you know gunning down people
in cars that last one though eight years
before canonical yeah that would have
made him very young would have been very
young young and and I can't see unless
say unless the witnesses got the age
wrong I just can't sir I just can't see
a serial killer going active and then
not start really acting up for a whole
eight years you don't talk about ya
meant you know eight years later he
starts doing all this [ __ ] about leaving
signs and contacting the cops and it
sounds unlikely it sounds like there's
something that that would be something
that he would do within months of your
first crime a weeks now let's talk a
little bit about probably the best-known
zodiac suspect and this is probably
because of Robert gray-smith books about
the crime and also the 2007 David
Fincher movie which was based on his
books which was just called zodiac and
that would be our thoroughly Alan Matt
fight that book you Tom I was the book I
read I believe yeah well he wrote - he
wrote one just called zodiac and one
that I think was called zodiac unmasked
yeah but um so Arthur Leigh Allen has
been the prime suspect for a long time
and it's kind of easy to see why um he
sort of looked like the sketches he was
sort of a big beefy guy although he was
taller than but he was about 6 1 was a
goofball which made me kind of thing and
now some people did think he was kind of
a weird and he was a pedophile that they
do know and he did actually get
convicted of that later on it even all
his family members were like yeah we
kept our children away from him because
he had everything and he got fired from
several jobs for that also but he
actually he came to the attention I
think
after the Lake Berryessa attack because
he'd been in the area scuba diving and
the weird thing about him was that when
they brought him in he seemed to like
volunteer information that they didn't
really ask for like yeah I had a bloody
knife in my car but it was from a
chicken that I killed it wasn't people
it wouldn't you know what I mean so and
they didn't really ask him about that
now one of the things that they thought
was interesting was that he had a watch
that was zodiac brand yeah it is the
Swiss brand of watch I remember and the
logo is that is the crosshair so it was
just on his watch he said yeah my mom
gave it to me for a present like two
years ago he did commercials for I
remember yeah so that so they thought
that was kind of strange now you know he
like I said he was a weird dude he was a
pedophile he did live in the area and
was familiar with the area so they
pretty much pursued this guy you know
over and over like over the edge they do
many search warrants and stuff although
when they searched his house he is
listed lived in his mom's basement like
you do and they didn't really find now
they found some alarming things they
found that he had an arsenal even though
he wasn't supposed to have it because he
was you know on probation or on parole
or whatever for the pedophilia type
stuff
they also found a bunch of [ __ ] for
making bombs and they found some actual
pipe bombs yeah I don't know why they
didn't arrest him for that but they
didn't expect that but they didn't find
anything that linked him and as many
search warrants as they you know as they
went through over the years because they
did it many many times they never found
anything that would link him to any of
the victims because they were looking
for any kind of trophy or anything that
would that would lead him to it and he
had a friend named Don Chaney and
apparently Don Chaney said that we were
out hunting 1:00 a.m. in Arthur Leigh
Allen and he specifically told me like
before this was before you know the the
first zodiac killing he's like he
specifically told me hey yeah I've been
reading the most dangerous game that's
like my favorite story and
I'm gonna hunt people and I'm gonna call
myself the zodiac and I'm just gonna
shoot people with I'm gonna tie a
flashlight to my gun and and he said
that he specifically said something
about shooting out the tires of a bus
and killing the kids when they come out
and like he said up to me yeah he said
like a lot of things like that now some
people have said Don Chaney is a
credible dude some people say not so
much that he's just making stuff up so I
don't really know now what I do know now
like everybody else when I read Robert
gray-smith book when I saw the movie
zodiac in 2007 I was like well obviously
that's the dude right yeah but the
problem is so he actually died when he
died DNA wasn't really a thing it was
just kind of in its infancy but the
investigators had the presence of mind
to like freeze some portions of his
brain just in case they needed it later
on
a little brandy had yeah I guess now so
they kept it now when they were able in
the past few years to get a DNA partial
DNA profile off the stamps and the
letter flaps from the zodiac letters it
wasn't a man yeah it didn't match him it
didn't match Don Cheney his friend
either so and also his fingerprints did
not match the fingerprint that they
found on Paul Stine's cab his palm print
did not match the palm print the latent
palm print that they found on one of
those zodiac letters and his handwriting
they made him write the zodiac letters
because he was ambidextrous so they made
him write them with both hands and the
handwriting was not a match yeah he was
kind of a super loser I mean yeah I
think he did all that attention
yeah aspired to be either zodiac I was
just playing around yeah the cops yeah
anybody was helping him and he actually
was on the news like they they
interviewed him like one I saw up like
part of it on a documentary where this
lady actually did score an interview
with him and he it's like he doesn't see
he seems kind of like I said like a
dirtbag but I I initially thought yeah
he sounded like the zodiac but now I
don't
think so yeah I'm skeptical it just
seems like so much of the forensic
evidence was against it was against it
and also I think he passed a polygraph
as well so it's and they never found and
like I said they went through they went
through his trailer his basement so many
times up in the Lincoln oh it's like all
they found was like like I said they
found bombs and stuff which that's not
good he also had no information about
the cases that you couldn't find out of
a newspaper right that's what I mean
yeah there were a lot of little details
that he wasn't aware of and just he was
toying around with them that's yeah I
kind of feel bad too cause like I
initially I thought he sounded like a
good suspect but now I think what the
deal was is that he was his thinking was
well they could never prove it was me
because I didn't do it
Shyama [ __ ] with them and trying to get
some free street cred and and you know
maybe get people in the media to think
that yeah he he's the zodiac and I can't
catch him
yeah you you weren't dealing with a
really intelligent guy really yeah you
know the guy was uh you know very I
would say low on the intellectual scale
you know he was he was he kind of
reminded me of the two dudes that the
confession machine guys oh Henry Lee
Lucas yeah yeah kind of like a Henry
yeah Lucas yeah they'll confess to that
confess I'm just saying I'm sure he did
kill a couple people but he's just like
confess yeah I killed though I killed
hundreds I think you I think I think he
was looking for me killed wondering a
little robbery yeah I think that's a
robbing a gas station and yeah he wasn't
confessed to like a hundred he knew he
would never be a free man for that one
homicide so he would just confess to
everything and make up stories and try
to get famous while I was in you know
behind bars in prison yeah and the
justice system liked it because they
could clear their books of unsolved
murders he'd go right oh yeah yeah we
did that he didn't know anything about
those cases yeah
but you know so like I said other than
him being the prime suspect there's a
there's a bunch of other ones some of
them like crazier than others
I think I mentioned on the black dahlia
show that Steve Hodel who wrote the book
The Black Dahlia Avenger and said that
his dad George Hill Hotel had killed the
Black Dahlia and that sounded sort of
reasonable
but then he kind of went off the rails I
guess he wanted some of that sweet book
publishing money and he wrote another
book called most evil in which he said
oh by the way my dad was also the zodiac
yeah which there is really no reason at
all to think that it's like it seems
like there's just no evidence for it at
all he does George Hill hotel looks
nothing like yeah the sketch his
handwriting looks nothing like you know
I mean it's just it's it's just silly
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go with the
official story
he killed the five canonical victims and
I don't believe he was ever caught and I
don't think I don't think he ever was a
suspect I'm gonna ever got him in their
sights
yeah now chances are he's dead well one
of the interesting things and I just saw
this recently so I don't know how
credible this is because here's the
thing and and why I brought up Steve
Hodel and George Hill hotel was that you
know everyone and their mom is like yeah
now my dad's the Zodiac killer - isn't
that the other now so this guy in 2007
comes his name is Dennis Kaufman and he
comes out and he says my stepdad Jack
Terence I think was the zodiac now the
reason that he thought this was because
apparently he was going through his
dad's stuff and he found the
executioner's hood with the symbol on it
hmm now that has been submitted to the
FBI for DNA analysis apparently the
results were inconclusive they couldn't
really get any good DNA off of it hmm
however um I saw an interview with this
guy and this guy really seems to believe
that his [ __ ] stepdad was the zodiac
they can damage it if they can date that
material back to that time there's a
good chance that that man had a [ __ ] ton
of handwriting samples
yeah of his stepdad and they submitted
them to a couple of you know I know
handwriting analysis not an exact
science but wha
but the handwriting was really similar I
mean it looked a lot like it sounds like
a good lead so and he showed pictures of
his stepdad and his stepdad
looked a lot like that drawing and the
thing is it's like do they have any DNA
samples fine
you know what I don't know well yeah I
think he's dead now but yeah yeah dig
him up there's probably DNA yeah yeah
cuz he couldn't have died that long ago
I would think but he says Dennis Kaufman
says I got my stepdad too cuz his
stepdad was dying and he's like so I got
him to write recorded him say like
essentially saying that he was the
Zodiac killer and they did play like
parts of the interview and stuff and it
does kind of sound like he's confessing
to some [ __ ] so like I said I don't know
it's like that's the thing it's hard to
know what to take seriously because
everybody's like yeah but it's like yeah
but it had to be somebody's somebody it
had to be somebody if they date that
hood to that time cuz the type of fabric
and everything maybe get some DNA off of
it you'd think that he'd have some hair
or some dander stuck up inside that
thing you get a DNA off of it you'd know
yeah then you could take exhume his body
get a sample there you know if it's not
too degraded yeah I think you should
they'd probably be alright you could
probably ID him I mean they do seem to
be taking it somewhat seriously so we'll
see where that goes um that may be in
yeah there was a another one there was a
guy named Louis Meyers who in 2014
actually confessed to a friend that he
because he was dying he had cirrhosis of
the liver and he said that he was the
Zodiac killer so yeah we'll see how that
goes that now this guy did actually go
to the same high school as some of the
victims so he was like around there he
had he was in the military he had the
same kind of boots like the wing-walker
okay so there are yes so it's not just
the fact that he said so there are some
kind of like associations and [ __ ] like
that they thought it was interesting
that in the period when no zodiac
letters came to the papers which was
yeah between 1970 was deployed 33 yet he
was overseas they were thinking at the
time and some of the symbols that he
used in his ciphers were like nautical
symbols and yeah some of them they
looked like they look like little
semaphore flags yeah and some of the you
know some of the knots that he tied were
Navy you
tied knots and one of one of the people
that evidently jumped out remember the
girls jumped out of the car
yeah Kathleen John's right she she
described it a navy type guy yeah they
made years maybe your Air Force right he
had a military style haircut and then
like I said spit polish he had he had
wing-walker boots and they said that you
would get those at a military px for
like walking around on that yeah
airplane wings it's like for maintenance
and stuff yeah but yeah those were the
kinds of those now before we go I want
to say now this is on the Wikipedia page
they actually don't name Edward Wayne
Edwards as one of the suspects for the
Zodiac but he does come up in some
crimes because a lot of crimes that he
actually did that they know that he did
commit were very zodiac esque so he is
actually a serial killer he died in 2011
he was also a bank robber you held up
gas station [ __ ] like that
but he was actually what he did was he
he had like a this kind of terrible
childhood and then he went into criminal
life like very early and then he ended
up going to prison and then he
supposedly there was a nice guard at
Leavenworth that turned his life around
he reformed he got married blah blah
blah and then he went on the lecture
circuit and he wrote a book like about
his reform and he went around like as a
motivational speaker right but then
later on he went back to a life of crime
so I guess he wasn't really reformed
then he went around shooting people yeah
so obviously he even turned up on like
some [ __ ] game shows and stuff like
to tell the truth and stuff like about
his reform and everything so he actually
did some murders later on in 1977 he did
a lover's lane murder to Billie Lovato
and Judy Stroud that was in Ohio I think
and then he did one in Wisconsin in 1980
these were called the sweetheart murders
that was Tim Pak and Kelly drew same
thing that he walks up to them in a car
and shoots him wonder why that was a
thing I don't know that there was a lot
of that though and like I said even
later and this is in my book to the
Atlanta Lovers Lane killing that was
that was a black guy it wasn't the same
guy but haters I guess but yeah it was
just like you kind of weird
some reason just walking how dare you
guys are getting it on Wow yeah yeah
weird you guys should be doing that
someone punish you yeah whatever yeah so
yeah so Edward Edwards so for the people
that he killed yet that he was convicted
for that it was two Lovers Lane type
murders the other murder that he was
convicted for was his stepson well it
was his adopted son even though he
legally wasn't adopted the kids name was
Danny Boy and he killed the kid for life
insurance so that was nice so yeah but
he got convicted of that so some people
think that he might have also been
responsible for one of the earlier
crimes I talked about Larry Payton in
Beverly Allen because he was in the area
at the time and he was actually one of
their first suspects and when they
picked him up he had a what appeared to
be a bullet wound in his arm which would
kind of go with the whole hey Larry got
off a shot at the attacker but he just
said oh I was out shooting like the
pheasants or so he's had some stupid
excuse I don't know but um so this guy
he's like I said he's dead now but he's
kind of one of those guys I think they a
couple years ago they made a documentary
called like the serial killer you've
never heard of or something like that
because they think he killed the shit's
on more people than they know of than
just the five that he was convicted of
and some people think that he might have
been the Zodiac as well so he's not a
name that comes up a lot but he is kind
of an interesting character and I wrote
about him some of my book also but I
think that's probably this is like a
huge huge humongous case and there's
just like something I wanted to get some
into the [ __ ] we actually covered a
lot of it we actually did yeah and I was
like I was gonna get a little bit into
you know kind of the stupider things but
I know anymore you have to react cheery
these books there are a bunch of little
details about the cave about these cases
they're interesting but it's not enough
to catch the guy they would have caught
it a long time yeah and like I said if
you really wanted and if you see want to
see all the letters they've all been
scanned and you can see him and
everything and you go to like zodiac
ciphers calm or the Zodiac killer calm
and it's just like thousands and
thousands of hours worth of information
about every possible thing you could
want to know about this
there were five homicides in a series of
mysterious letters it was an interesting
case the guy [ __ ] played it up into
something scared the [ __ ] out of the
cops was writing letters to the damn
newspapers making weird demands and then
the guy just kind of evaporated yeah so
that's I I think I think he burned out
like I said at the beginning of the show
you know I mentioned that they're trying
to do that GED match that genealogy
thing trying to catch this son of a
[ __ ] too so maybe they will they caught
the Golden State killer and we never
thought that would happen
am i catching but I think he's gonna be
dead well that's gonna get a DNA match
and go yeah that guy he's dead he's down
the ground that's gonna be something
like that what everybody just wants to
know who it is
yeah even though it'll pry I know this
is kind of a [ __ ] up thing to say
but it's like I think people will be
disappointed yeah that's it yes he's
like such a boogeyman yeah he killed he
killed some people he was kind of dorky
and then he got he got tired of it it
was afraid of getting caught we'll see
that's what kind of made me think of
that Jack Terrence guy that that was
that guy's stepdad that he was talking
about and he said during the interview
he's like yeah I just got burned out
yeah got too old blah blah that's what
the guy said like in the interview issue
I don't know if he's really the zodiac
job or where they didn't get doesn't
give him the satisfaction he was looking
for guys know what to do they do kind of
age out generally I mean that's what
having a golden snake killer yeah yeah
so anyway this has been a kind of a fun
show I'd spent days and days and days
like researching this cuz I this is like
a really fascinating case to me so like
I said if you want to see more
information obviously you can go pretty
much any more oh there's just like tons
of [ __ ] everywhere you can read for
hours and hours and you'll just never
run out of stuff to read so that will do
it for episode 109 remember if you liked
the show to like share subscribe on all
your social media and share with all
your friends it helps us out a lot if
you'd like to financially support the
show you can go to our patreon page at
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast or
you can go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast wordpress comm and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account make sure and check out
our last movie review which was the evil
from 1978 a haunted house movie it's
very cool and they actually
watch it on YouTube for free if you want
to and also check out my games on jello
games which is on the game crafter my
book the faceless villain is out in
print and should be out an e-book by the
time this episode goes up tech check out
Tom's shitty no yes to DS on Facebook if
you want to see his little capsule funny
capsule reviews about guys are talking
about movie it's a sausage fest like he
says so if you don't mind waiting into
the sauce into the waiting fields of
sausage yeah then go and check it out
and that will do it for this installment
we will see you next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
first
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]